All right, it's 9:20. Time to start.
Good morning. How's everyone doing?
Uh, so today we're going to start
talking about the Chandandy Lamport
snapshot algorithm in more detail. Uh,
we started to talk about it last time,
but we didn't really, uh, write down the
algorithm. Uh, we just looked at a very
simple example. So today I'm hoping to
go back to that simple simple example uh
but uh but actually write down what the
algorithm does and then we'll go through
uh a slightly more sophisticated
example. Um
before I get into that though uh I want
to come really briefly back to the quiz
question last time. Uh so as you know we
do these quizzes uh every day in lecture
and uh most of the time I'm pretty happy
with the answers to the quiz questions.
Uh but it seems like a lot of people
struggled with this one last time. Uh so
this was the quiz question last time.
Can you use vector vector clocks to
establish a total order of events in a
distributed system?
And uh so the answer is no. And the
reason why uh just to sketch it out for
you um to go back to to the to the doc
cam uh
so here's our uh example of a total
order anomaly again and we talked about
this last time but uh um it might not
have been quite spelled out in detail.
Uh so if you so if you have a a pattern
of messages that goes like this and you
tried to put vector clocks on those
messages
uh according to the causal broadcast uh
algorithm that we talked about uh well
um then the vector clock on on this
message here um because so so suppose
these are P1, P2,
P3 and P4. um the vector clock sent uh
uh along with this message uh would be 1
0 0 0. So that would be the vector clock
sent along with both of these messages.
And the one sent along with this one
would be 0 0 0 1. And just to refresh
your memory, that's because uh the
vector clock counts this one send in the
in uh that's happening on the sender as
an event. Um so these messages arrive
here, they get delivered. Um, this
message arrive arrives here. The current
clock on P3 is 00001. The clock on the
arriving message is one 0 0. Um, that's
okay to deliver because it's one bigger
than the current uh clock on the process
in the sender's position. Uh, and it's
less than or equal to uh the current
clock on on the receiver
um in every other position. Um so this
is okay to deliver as well. And then the
and likewise this one is okay to
deliver. So these two events here
um
uh if you were to if you were to use the
vector clocks algorithm that we talked
about before where we actually um assign
uh uh vector clocks or where we actually
count both sends and receives as events.
Um what if you did that? What if you
were just kind of looking at this
exchange of of messages after the fact
and you wanted to assign vector clocks
to events? Well, okay. So, this one
would be 1 0 0 0 here. This one would be
0 0 0 1. Suppose you counted the receive
as an event here. Then this would be
like one one
0 0 here. And then this would be 0 0 one
one.
Um and then this coming in here would be
would be what it would you would take
the max right. So it would be uh one one
0 one and this one here you would again
take the max. So it would be 1 0 1 1. So
these would be the vector clocks of
these two events at the end of this
whole run if you were using the the the
vector clocks algorithm that I
originally showed. Um yeah. Okay. Okay,
so there's a question in chat about
about broadcasting. Um, so uh forget
about the causal broadcast uh algorithm
for a moment. Um, and just think about
assigning uh um uh
vector clocks to events. Um, oh, okay. A
question in chat is uh um don't we count
receives as events? As events. Yeah,
that's right. Okay, so this that's
right. I'm sorry I got it wrong. So this
would be 0021 here and then this would
be 1 12 0 1 here.
Um so so the algorithm for assigning
vector clocks to events that I
originally showed works regardless of
whether they're broadcast messages or
not. So just think about that. Um so we
get here right and we have these two
events which have these two vector
clocks one 12 0 1
and 1 02 1.
Do these two vector clocks have an order
according to the order of vector clocks
that we talked about?
No, they wouldn't. So, it's not the case
that this one is bigger, right? Because
it's smaller in in this position. And
it's not the case that this one is
bigger because it's smaller in this
position. So, there's no order here. So,
in other words, these two events here
are concurrent
because their clocks don't have an
order. And so,
vector clocks alone aren't enough to
establish a total order. That's kind of
the point in fact. Uh so
some people struggled with this
question. Um and in fact I got I got
some kind of interesting answers to the
question. Uh uh some people said things
like well no you can't establish a total
of order of events with vector clocks
because events can fail. Like there was
some discussion of failure. Um but
failure I mean even leaving aside
failure uh this uh this fact uh that you
can't establish a total order of events
uh with vector clocks is still true uh
because of basically what I illustrated
here because vector clocks uh just like
the happens before relation is a is a
partial order the ve vector clocks
exactly capture the happens before
relation they give you nothing more nor
less than the happens before relation.
And so the happens before relation gives
you gives you a partial order. Vector
clocks give you a partial order. They
don't give you a total order. Um okay,
that's kind of all there is to say about
that. U but I wanted to bring that up uh
because it it seemed like there was
there was a little bit of confusion. Uh
but today we're going to go back to
talking about um the Chandandy Lamport
algorithm. Okay, so
Chandandy Lamport, it's an algorithm for
taking a snapshot of the state of a
distributed system and it works by uh
having every process uh snapshot its own
state in a way that can then be put
together in a way that makes sense. Um
and any an interesting thing about the
Chandandy Lamport algorithm is that any
process can start it. uh it doesn't have
to be uh um there there doesn't have to
be like one designated coordinator
process or anything like that. Um, so
any process can begin it and that
process does not have to announce to
everybody, okay, I'm gonna start the
snapshot now. Uh, it can just go ahead
and start because it turns out, as we'll
talk about later, um, it turns out that
there's no problem if two processes
happen to start taking a snapshot at the
same time without coordinating with each
other. Um, that turns out actually not
to cause a problem for the algorithm. Um
so just for the sake of example we'll
say that there's one particular
particular initiator process for now but
it turns out that nothing would go wrong
um if there were more than one. Um so
question in chat does the Chandandy
Lamport algorithm help us avoid that
total order anomaly? No it does not. So
this is different topic now. Um I was
only talking about that because I wanted
to clear up any confusion from that
leftover quiz question yesterday. So
this is a different topic. Okay. So this
is about taking snapshots in order to
look at the state of a distributed
system at a given moment and then maybe
use that snapshot for things like
debugging or answering questions about
the system.
Okay. So we're going to say one
particular process kicks things off. Uh
and we'll call it the initiator process.
So here's what the initiator process
does. The first thing it does is it
records its own state.
Right after doing that, before doing
anything else, it has to send
a marker message.
And we're going to draw those using
squiggly lines
out on
all its outgoing channels.
So it has to it has to do that right
after recording its own state before
doing anything else. It's important that
that happens otherwise bugs could be
introduced. And it
starts recording
the messages
it receives
on all.
It's incoming
channels.
Um so in our example from last time
uh let's say that process one is the
initiator.
So P1 is the initiator.
Let's say it takes a snapshot, starts
taking a snapshot right after this event
A. So here's its snapshot of its of its
state. We'll call that S1.
So it records its state. It'll send a
marker. We'll say this message C happens
over here. This is the same example as
last time.
um it sends a marker
and it sends that marker right after it
snapshots its state. Also, it starts
recording on all its incoming channels.
Um so in this case, uh it only has one
incoming channel, the channel from
process 2. And we said that the
convention for naming channels uh is
that uh so channel C21
is the channel from process two to
process one. Um so process one is now
recording
on channel C21. That's an equals sign
there.
So in general uh channel CIG is the
channel that goes from process I to
process J. That's just the naming
convention that we're going to use. Uh
somebody in chat asks what's included in
a snapshot. So a snapshot uh um captures
all the events that have happened on
that process so far ever. Um so in other
words, it's the current state of that
process.
Okay, so that's what the initiator
process does. Um next thing we have to
talk about is is what happens when
somebody receives a marker message. uh
as just happened over here on P2.
Uh so
we'll bring this initiator page back
later if we need to look at it.
Um, so
receiving a marker.
Receiving a marker message.
We're going to say when
process
PI
gets a marker
message
on
let's say
channel C
KI I. So that's the channel from process
PK to process PI.
There are two cases in this case. So if
it's the first marker message that
process PI has seen, here's what
happens.
pi records its state.
PI marks
channel CKI,
the channel that the marker message came
in on as empty.
NPI sends a marker out itself
on
all its outgoing channels.
So its outgoing channels because it's
process I all of its outgoing channels
are going to start with I. So, CIG
represents all of its outgoing channels.
And then finally
it starts recording
incoming messages
on all its incoming channels.
except
CKI which was the one that the message
came in on.
So that's a lot of stuff. Um so the the
short version of this
record your state
and
start recording incoming messages.
That's what you do
when you receive a marker message and
it's the first marker message that
you've seen.
So that's one case. The other case is if
it's not the first marker message that
you've seen. So um what is what counts
as seeing a marker message? Well, we say
that uh um
if you've uh if you've done anything at
all um uh with a marker message uh then
you've seen a marker message. So even
sending a marker message counts as
seeing one.
So let's let's look at the other case.
I'll put this back here so that we
remember the names of things.
So we're looking at the case when
process PI gets a marker message on
channel CKI
and
Process I has already
seen
a marker.
Here's what we do.
PI stops recording
on
channel CKI
because it's already seen a marker. We
know it already it had started recording
right when it saw a marker previously.
Um so we know that it's already
recording on this channel. Uh so when it
receives a marker message on this
channel uh and it's not the first marker
it's seen, it can stop recording on that
channel now. And what does it do?
It sets
that channels
final state
as the sequence of all the incoming
messages.
that arrived
on CKI
since recording began.
So if we look at our picture
so we were in a situation like this
right where we had
captured the state on P1 P1 had sent a
marker
Maybe there were some events over here.
So in our example when two when P2
receives the marker message um it
records its state
and this is going to be the um uh the
case where it's the first marker message
that that that P2 has seen right so it
records its state uh it marks the
channel that the marker marker message
came in on is empty. It has no other
incoming channels to record on. So, it
doesn't have to do that. And then it's
going to send a marker back to P1.
Um, and it's going to mark channel one
two as empty. Now, process one over here
was recording. Recall that it was
recording
on the channel on its incoming channel
right from the time that it sent this
marker message up. Process two over here
is going to set C12 as empty.
So what's going to happen here on P1? So
this is actually the already seen a
marker case when this marker message
right here is received on P1. At that
point P1 stops recording on the channel
that the marker message came in on and
it sets that channel's final state as
the sequence of all the incoming
messages that arrived there since
recording began. So in this case the way
that I drew the picture this time we
said that this event uh D is the arrival
of this message from P2. Um
had this had this happened differently
um had this marker message over here uh
arrived earlier then maybe this wouldn't
have happened right now one interesting
thing to point out is that remember how
we said that in the Chandandy Lamport
algorithm there are these channels and
channels behave like FIFO cues well
because of that FIFO behavior uh
messages can't cross over each other. So
you're not going to have uh FIFO
anomalies
so this uh
this FIFO anomaly won't happen and
furthermore a FIFO anomaly like this a
message crossing over won't happen
between an application message and a
marker message either. So it's actually
very important that this application
message from here from event C to event
D and this marker message that got sent
here u these aren't going to cross over.
So if event C happened over here and it
got included in the snapshot and then
the marker message got sent after that
um well this marker message won't cross
over the application message uh in the
channel from um from process two to
process one. Um so if this send happened
here um it essentially means that
uh
this marker message here cannot arrive
on P1 until this uh message arrives
first.
Okay.
So in this particular picture C21 is
going to stop recording now and it has
one message in it. um
that message doesn't really have a name
but we'll call it like uh CO D to
represent the fact that it was a message
from event C to event D.
So this assumption that messages arrive
in FIFO order is very important. Uh
channels act like FIFO cues.
Okay.
So now what are we done taking our
snapshot?
Uh well,
we've taken a snapshot on both channels
or we've taken a snapshot of the state,
excuse me, on both processes.
Um so we've got state snapshot on on
snapshots on both processes. And the
other thing that processes were supposed
to snapshot uh were the channel states.
Well, process one only had one incoming
channel to record on, and it did. It
recorded the message uh from C to D on
its incoming channel. Process two only
had one incoming channel to record on uh
channel one two and that one ended up
being empty. Um so we are actually done.
We have everything recorded. We got the
state of process one. We got the state
of process 2 and we got the state of
both channels. Um so this snapshot is
done.
Yay.
So hopefully we I convinced you last
time that this snapshot makes sense
um in the sense that uh there's nothing
included in it that would uh that would
violate causality. Right? So B is in
there which means that the thing that
happened before B A is in there as well.
Uh now depending on how long this marker
message here took right to get from
process one to process two um different
things could have occurred right so had
this marker message been just a little
bit slower right it might have arrived
like right here uh before event C
happened in which case process 2's
snapshot of it of its own state would
only capture B and not C. Um, and then
this marker message would get sent back
like this. Now, here's where that FIFO
thing is really important, right?
Because suppose that this marker message
got sent here right after the snapshot
was taken. This is why it's so important
that you send markers immediately after
taking a snapshot before doing anything
else. Um, but suppose it had crossed
over here. Suppose it had crossed over
like this.
Well, then when process one got that, it
would take a snapshot like this at the
point where it got the marker, right?
And then that would be no good because
then these would both be included in the
snapshot. Um, but C wouldn't and then
and then we would have a problem. Uh, so
this FIFO behavior is actually very
important.
Okay,
so I think I wrote down um the the most
important things that we need to know
for the algorithm. Um so here again is
the is is what the initiator process
does. Um so it records its own state. It
sends a marker message on all its uh
outgoing channels and it starts
recording on all its incoming channels.
Uh and then coming back to the cases of
what you do when you when you receive a
marker message. Um here's the first page
of that. So when a process PI gets a
marker message on on one of its incoming
channels, um if it's the first marker
that it's seen, it records its state. So
you record your state just as soon as
you see the first marker message.
um you mark the channel that that marker
message came in on as empty and you send
a marker out on all your outgoing
channels
and then you start recording incoming
messages uh on all your incoming
channels except for that one that the
marker message that just came in on
because that one you've you've marked
that one as empty.
And then the case where you've already
seen a marker
and you get another marker,
you stop recording on the channel that
the marker message came in on and you
set that channel's final state as the
sequence of all the incoming messages
that came in on that channel since
recording began. Okay, so there was a
question right here about why C12 was
empty. Okay, so C12 is the channel from
from process one to process 2. Um, so
it's empty because uh when process 2
receives this marker message wherever
wherever it is that it comes in, let's
say that it came in in here. Um, so the
first thing this process does is record
its state. Um and then the it the next
thing it does is it marks the the
channel that the marker message came in
on as empty. Uh and it only has this one
incoming channel. Um so that
uh that part of the algorithm is right
here where we say um the process marks
the channel that the first marker comes
in on as empty.
Okay, so that's the Chandandy Lamport
algorithm for a really simple example.
Um, but hopefully even that simple
example kind of illustrated um why it is
that the algorithm cares about uh um
about FIFO ordering. Uh and I want to
walk through a more sophisticated
example. Now
there's a couple of questions here.
Yeah. So so some some folks are asking
like what's this for again? What what
problem does this solve? Yeah. Okay. So
the problem that this solves is it's
really hard to know the state of a
running distributed system, right? Um
and you could ask everybody, you know,
what their state is, right? But when you
do,
how do you know that? You know, if you
ask one process what its state is and
you ask another process what its state
is and you ask another process what its
state is. Um then
how do you know that those when you when
you put those together that they're
going to make sense? And in particular,
if you if you even if you tell
everybody, okay, I want to know what
your state is at time so and so, then um
those that won't help because if unless
their clocks are perfectly synchronized
uh which in practice isn't really
possible then um then then you can't you
can't get a coherent picture. So the
reason one reason why it's called a
snapshot algorithm and I could I could
take a I could use an analogy which was
actually used in the original paper
about snapshots. Um let's say that you
want to take a panoramic photo of a
bunch of birds flying through the sky.
Um and this is this is Chandandy and
Lamport's analogy. Um so
uh you can't take a picture of the whole
sky at once, right? Um, but you also
don't want uh you also want it to be an
accurate picture, right? Like you don't
want the same bird to appear twice in
the picture. Uh, and you don't want to
leave out any birds. Um, so so how do
you do it? Like how do you stitch
together all of those pictures in in uh
into one coherent photo? Um and so this
algorithm
provides a way to take individual
snapshots on the different processes in
a way that you can stitch them together.
Now you might ask what like why why do
you need a global snapshot of the
system? So well one reason is that um so
there's there's um there's kind of two
reasons right um
so in debugging you often encounter this
situation where um where something goes
wrong and then um from that point
onwards uh it it's like after a given
point things are wrong from that point
forward.
So if you want to know if that bug
happened at some point in the in the
past, right, you need to know a snapshot
of the system right now to know if it if
that bug ever occurred. Uh so in for so
an example of that might be deadlock,
right? So if you have some kind of
deadlock um and at some point in the
past a deadlock happened and now things
are deadlocked um you might want to take
a snapshot and then of of the system in
its current state u and a deadlock would
be I guess like one processes waiting
for two process are each waiting on the
other for something. Um so uh
one way to try to figure out if you have
such a deadlock going on right now in
your system is to take a snapshot and
then inspect the snapshot for deadlocks.
Yeah. Yeah. So, one person just asked in
chat um
uh so a marker message is considered
seen by a process also when that process
has sent it out as well. That's correct.
Yeah. So, seeing so sending a marker
message counts as seeing.
I haven't been looking at Twitch chat at
all. So, there could be like all kinds
of stuff being said there. I'll take a
look at it now.
Okay.
So, um, I want to start to walk through
a a fancier example. Oh, that's funny.
So, somebody did ask a question in
Twitch chat. Um, but then as soon as I
went to VOD view, the the question
disappeared. So, I don't know what
happened there. Um, maybe it'll reappear
or maybe ask your question again,
viewer. All right. Um, so this is an
example of the of a run of the Chandandy
Lamport algorithm that that I've seen
other people use.
Um, and I even wrote a whole blog post
about it.
Um,
and I I I think it's a it's a good
example. Um, but I don't I don't think
it's necessarily always well explained.
Um, so I'm going to try to explain it uh
in a way that I think makes sense. Um,
so this is seriously a commonly used
example. uh like if you look online for
lecture notes about the Chandandy
Lamport algorithm um there there are
multiple people who use this exact
example
and I think it was originally uh from
uh Indie Gupta so thanks to him for
coming up with it.
Okay,
so here's our set of events. We got
three processes. Um, we've got a bunch
of events A through K.
Uh, we'll say that process one is the
initiator.
Okay, the the question on Twitch chat is
back. Um, so the question was once
you've marked a channel empty, uh, what
happens if you received another message
on that channel? Do you just ignore it?
Yes, that is exactly what you do. So
once a channel has been marked as empty,
you're you're done with that channel.
Um, so that that could happen, right?
And it would mean that your snapshot
wouldn't necessarily be the most
up-to-date snapshot, but it would still
be a consistent uh snapshot in the sense
that it would be coherent with the other
snapshots that you're that you're
stitching it together with.
Another question uh on Slack is what
happens when two processes initiate at
once. So that actually turns out to not
be a problem. Uh and uh if we get a
chance, we'll uh we'll look at a more
detailed example of that. Uh but if you
want to you can look at the rules that
we wrote down and try to work it out
yourself and say okay suppose these two
processes both decide to be the
initiator. Um you can it turns out that
that's actually okay. They can both send
marker messages and it's okay if there's
not even any distinguishing between the
the two marker the marker messages from
them both. Um like it works it ends up
actually working out and producing a
coherent snapshot. That's one of the
most fascinating things about this
algorithm from my point of view. So
we're we we're we're going to be talking
about many distributed algorithms in
this course. But some of some
distributed algorithms are also what I
would call decentralized algorithms. Um
and by decentralized I mean that uh
anyone can start them right there's no
uh like designated uh coordinator who
has to be in charge. and decent. So
decentralized algorithms are like a
subset of of distributed algorithms and
they're often um they're they have to be
written in this really interesting way
that uh that makes it possible for uh um
for anyone or multiple multiple
participants at once uh to uh to
initiate them. And that's actually true
of of this algorithm which is which is
one of the things that I I think makes
it so cool. Okay, so let's do this. Um,
let's say that that P1 is the initiator
and let's say that it it initiates a
snapshot right here, right after event
B.
Okay, we'll call that S1, the snapshot
that it takes of its own state right
there. Okay, so what does P1 do? It
records its own state. It's going to
send markers out to process 2 and
process 3, and it's going to start
recording on its incoming channels. Uh
so right here it's going to send marker
messages out.
Um so let's say that it sends a marker
like this
over to process three. In my example,
the marker messages uh ignore the fact
that that's a curvy line. In my example,
it it um I want to be faithful to the
the example that I wrote up before. And
and in my in my example, um the marker
message arrives before event J uh on
process 3. And then this other marker
message, we're going to imagine that
this one is a little bit slow.
So it actually takes all the way to
after event H on process 2 to arrive.
So it sends its markers out and it
starts recording on its incoming
channels. So process one has two
incoming channels, right? uh uh C21
and C31.
So right now both of those uh are
recording and so they're both empty for
now.
By the way, um,
how many marker messages do you think
this algorithm is is eventually going to
send?
Yeah. So, so this one will send six,
right? Um in general everybody has to
send a marker to everybody else right so
if there are n processes
uh all of them are going to send n minus
one marker messages yeah so in general
it's going to be n * n minus one
so that's a lot right um so in this case
that'll be that'll be six right because
3 * 2 is six Um uh but yeah in general
it's going to send this this quadratic
number of marker messages and this is I
think typical of distributed algorithms
and especially of decentralized algorith
algorithms. They have to send a lot of
messages in order to work. Uh so this
algorithm is not not necessarily what
you might call efficient but you can't
actually do any better. Um, okay. So,
um,
back to back to the algorithm. So, I
intentionally made this one here slow so
you can see that the algorithm will
still work even if it if it takes a
while for the messages to arrive. U, by
the way, this algorithm does actually
assume that messages don't get lost. So,
we talked about reliable delivery really
briefly before. um this algorithm
assumes that that we have reliable
delivery of messages but they could be
slow.
Okay, let's talk about what happens
right here on P3. P3 gets the marker
message.
Oh, N here uh somebody was asking in
chat. N is just the number of processes
in this system.
So the number of messages the number of
marker messages that get sent by this
algorithm is n * n minus one uh if n is
the number of processes that are
participating.
Okay. So here um so P3 gets the marker
message right here. What happens? Um has
P3 ever seen a marker message before?
No. So what does it do? It records its
own state.
We'll call that S3.
And now it has to send marker messages
on its outgoing channels uh to P2 and
P1.
And it has to start recording incoming
messages on all of its incoming channels
except the one that it received the
marker message on. So it received the
marker message on this channel. Um but
it has another incoming channel right
from presses 2. Um so it has to start
recording
uh on channel uh C23.
So
C13 is going to be empty
because that's the one that it received
the marker message on. C23
it's recording
and now it's going to send its marker
messages out. Right.
Um, so it its marker messages are going
to go out to P1 and P2.
Let's say that they go like this.
So there are those marker messages, but
when by the time we're done, we're going
to have six squiggly lines on this
picture.
So let's look at P1. Here's where the
marker message arrived on P1.
This marker message is not the first
that P1 has seen because P1 originally
sent them. So what does P1 do?
Um, can somebody refresh my memory? What
does a process do when it receives a
marker message and it's not the first
marker message that it's originally
seeing?
Yeah. So, it has to stop recording.
on that channel.
So, it was recording right on this
channel C31, which was the channel from
P3. So, it's going to stop recording on
that channel. Uh, it didn't receive any
messages on that channel while it was
recording anyway. Um, so C31 state is
now empty.
Okay.
Now, let's look at the marker message uh
from P3 to P2. This one that came in
right here. What does P2 do when it uh
when it gets that marker message?
Yeah, it has to record its state. It
didn't do that yet. So, it had better do
that.
So, finally P2 gets to record its state
and it's going to loop up all these
events here.
And then what it does is it marks the
state of the channel that the marker
arrived on as empty. The channel that
the marker arrived on was the channel
from P3. So
C32
is empty.
And then its other incoming channel was
C12, right? The channel from process
one. Um, so it's now recording on that
channel and it has to send out its own
marker messages
uh on its on its own outgoing channels
uh to P1 and P3. Let's say that those
get sent right here.
Okay, so this is the current state of
the system.
And now this marker message that we got
that we sent from P1 way back a long
time ago finally gets to P2 right here.
So because P2 has already seen uh seen a
marker
um what does it do in this case?
Yeah. So it uh it can stop recording
right on the channel that the marker
came in on which was uh which was C12,
right? That was this one here. Uh but it
has to set the final state there as all
of the incoming messages that that
arrived
uh on that channel since since recording
began. Um so were any messages received
on this channel C12 since recording
began? Um doesn't look like it to me. It
started recording right here when it
started taking this when it when it when
it got its first marker message. So it
didn't receive any. Um, so I think that
this can now be marked as empty as well.
Okay.
Now what?
So now process 2's job is done, right?
It recorded it its own state and both of
its incoming channels are now done.
They're both marked as empty. Um, but we
still have two things to finish up,
right? We still have process one has a
channel that's still recording and
process 3 has a channel that's still
recording. Uh, well, that's handled by
the fact that um these marker messages
right here were sent out from P2. Um, so
P1 needs to finish up. It wait was
waiting for this marker to come in uh
from from process 2 so that it could
stop recording on channel 21.
Uh, and look, there's that marker
message.
So, did anything get recorded
um on channel 21 while it was recording?
It started recording way up here. Did
anything get recorded on that channel?
Yeah. So, there was this message right
here, right? Whose send was H and
receive was D, right? So that that
should go into C21's final channel
state. So this message um
H2D here.
Okay.
And then finally P3 gets the last
message marker message that it was
waiting for from P2. Um did any messages
come in on P3 while it was recording on
that channel?
Doesn't look like it to me. So, no
messages came in there while it was
recording. So, this can be empty as
well.
Okay. So now all of the process states
uh S1, S2, and S3
are recorded and all of the channel
states are recorded.
So we're done.
So
I want to address a question that that
came up in chat. Uh so somebody asked uh
there's actually a couple of good
questions here. Um
one person asked, can you have multiple
executions of the algorithm running
concurrently? So yeah, absolutely you
can. So that's um that's kind of what I
was getting at when I said that this
algorithm could be decentralized, right?
So it turns out that it's actually okay
if like if process one decided to
initiate this snapshot right here um and
process three over here uh of its own
valition decided that it was also going
to initiate a snapshot and they both
decided to snapshot their own state and
send out marker messages. It turns out
that that actually still works.
Uh so that's one of the one of the
really appealing aspects of this uh of
this algorithm.
Uh let me see if there were any
questions that I missed on Slack.
Uh somebody asked the channel is is the
channel marked empty before and after
the trading of the marker messages. Uh
so our our rule for when things are set
to empty uh to go back to the um what I
wrote out before. Um so that happens
when uh
uh
when you get a marker message and it's
the first marker message you've ever
seen. At that point uh you mark the
channel that the marker message came in
on as empty.
Uh so
when you get a marker message uh on a
channel that's when you can uh that
that's when you can mark it as empty. So
the question was like the channel is
marked empty before and after the
trading of marker messages. I'm not
sure. Um oh so here's another great
question in chat. Uh how does the entire
system know when the snapshot is done?
Great question.
Um,
so
well
when does when does a given process know
that it's done?
Yeah. So well you know that you you're
done. Okay. So somebody said when it's
received N minus one markers. So you
definitely have to have received N minus
one markers. Um uh
so and then somebody else said all
incoming channels marked empty. Well,
no, not necessarily, right? Because like
the state might end up being something
like this, right? Uh where it's not
empty. So I would say a process knows
it's done um when it's recorded its own
state and it's recorded the state of all
of its incoming channels. So you might
not know what's going on anywhere else,
right? But you know that you're done
when you've recorded your own state and
you've recorded the state of all your
incoming channels.
Uh so just like we don't have a global
clock in a distributed system, we also
un unless you decided to have some
coordinator process that went out and uh
and and checked with everybody and said,
"Okay, are you done snapshotting
yourself?" Uh and you could have that,
right? That could be something you could
do. Um but then that would that would
introduce uh uh
um because because you had this single
coordinator process. What if the
coordinator failed, right? Um so that's
something that you could do. So what you
would do is you would run the snapshot
algorithm to have everybody snapshot
their own state. Um and then if you
wanted to then you could maybe like
elect somebody to be the coordinator. um
and then have that coordinator go out
and collect up all of the snapshots that
were taken on the on the individual
states. So there's kind of there's kind
of two questions here like how does the
entire system know when the snapshot is
done? Um so that's kind of a problem
that gets solved externally to the
Chandandy Lamport algorithm. So all the
Chandandy Lamport algorithm does is
uh establish a way for every process to
take its own individual snapshot such
that when those snapshots are later
stitched together by something external
to the algorithm then they'll make
sense. Uh so that's that's kind of a
separate problem. Uh but the other issue
is do you know that this actually
terminates? Um, so it turns out that it
it does and there's a proof of that in
the paper by Chandandy and Lamport. Um,
but we'll we'll kind of give an informal
argument as to why it does. Um, so
before I I move on, uh, I want to ask a
quiz question.
So here is today's quiz question.
which I will share in chat.
We'll wait another couple minutes.
Oh, so there's a question uh in uh in
chat which is why doesn't the algorithm
record internal events?
uh like C or J. So going back to the
picture,
uh so we had a couple of internal events
in this picture were C or J. Uh wouldn't
we expect snapshots to do that? Yeah,
absolutely we would. The only reason
that they didn't get recorded is because
that's uh that's not the moment that the
um that the markers arrived. So at the
moment when P1 decided to snapshot its
own state, uh C hadn't happened yet,
right? And then at the moment when this
this marker arrived over here on P3, J
hadn't happened yet. But if it had then
then yeah absolutely that would have
been included. So if there had been some
uh internal event right here, call it L
on process 2, then that definitely would
have been included in the snapshot. It's
just that in this particular picture, it
happened not to have been.
All right. So, um
I want to talk a little bit about these
big picture things um that we talked
about briefly. Um
we're almost out of time. Uh but I want
to um I want to talk about this this um
uh this question of of
the of of the Chandandy Lamport
algorithm terminating.
So
this algorithm what do you think do you
think this algorithm is guaranteed to
terminate? Well okay so what does it
have to do right? Well, it has to record
the state of every process
uh and it has to record the state of
every channel.
So
you can kind of think about termination
on on this perprocess basis, right? So a
particular process is responsible for
recording its own state and it's
responsible for recording the state of
its incoming channels. So the informal
argument for termination is if that
terminates for every process, if if
recording its own state and the state of
its incoming channels terminates, then
you know if you can ensure that every
process can take care of the piece of
the overall picture that it's
responsible for, then we know that the
whole thing can terminate. So what's the
argument for every process being able to
take care of its own piece? Well, it's
pretty straightforward, right? like
recording its own state is easy. Um
we're assuming that messages are
reliably delivered, right? And we're
assuming um so so we're making we're
making a lot of assumptions here. We're
we're assuming that that that that the
messages are reliably delivered. Um
we're also assuming that processes don't
crash. Um so we'll come back to that
later. Um but sooner or later, every
process should receive a marker message
on all of its incoming channels. Um, and
then
the other piece that you have to get
done is is is recording the state of the
channels. Um, you know, it's okay to
stop recording on a channel when you
receive a marker. Basically, everybody,
you know, we know that everybody
receives a marker on every one of its
incoming channels because the algorithm
has every process send a marker out on
all its outgoing channels. And one
process's outgoing channel is somebody
else's incoming channel. So that's an
informal argument for the Chandandy
Lamport algorithm terminating. Uh we're
going to talk more about this next time
and we're going to talk more about the
assumptions that this algorithm makes.
Uh but we're out of time for today. So
uh next time we're going to talk more
about these uh um kind of big picture
aspects of this algorithm. Uh and we'll
and we'll talk a little bit more about
um uh
uh something else that that that came up
today um which was uh which was what I
just said about this assumption that
processes don't crash. And that will
hopefully lead us a little bit more into
the next part of the course which is
going to talk more about failure.
So, I'll see you next